they were both gonna be filming at the
same time on the same day and then that
changed when did that actually change in
Y well we were seeing the movies like
you know because these movies are so big
and so complex and there are some
characters who involved you know there
was an idea that we would sort of mix
both movies in kind of you know we do do
it hug cross for them in a way but you
get closer and deeper into production
the movies were so complex and so hard
to wrangle just for our own process and
I think everybody's process involved on
a creative level we need to do this
separate the two and really think about
them not falter but we're both very
different movies and we wanted to treat
them a very different movie and just
separating them you know we did shoot
them back-to-back so it literally we
finished shooting the infinity war and
we rolled right into the next event
which is why we look as old as we were
we were literally shooting for a
straight year without you know stopping
again it was very intense very difficult
year those challenges yeah good thing
they're still does but yeah we just so
we did if you did separate them just
because it was so complex at what point
in pre-production did you realize it's
not gonna work
you're starting to having correction
either lasting up to nine it's ten hours
because you have to talk about one movie
and once they're doing that people are
getting confused about what's in it
you know it was draining everyone's
energy and resources to try to think
that each of these movies is expensive
as me to get and which moves are very
very events of complicated and difficult
and it's very difficult on accrual Ivan
to agent to retain and weave a spell
right